so I don't know where you told the story
about you what you went on a date was it
in New York you went on this date yeah I
went on that day in New York but this
woman didn't know who you were
yes and it was perfect because you know
basically I know what Lando and he gave
me some advice before Star Wars 7 came
out and his advice was you know try and
secure right trying to secure the love
of your life before this stuff happens
and I did and I done the whole process
you didn't know why I did until we were
driving through Times Square she goes
what do you do for a living
looked up and I said that was me over
[Music]
yeah I blocked out my phone I mean that
picture yourself just affected her kind
of starts in the guy with a huge seamer
[Laughter]
of people knowing who you were where was
it in the supermarket when you had the
yeah I was in you know the first time
that happened to me where I was
recognized by somebody yeah was it was
before Lord of the Rings he come out and
I was so I was like 23 or 22 or
something but I was walking through a
supermarket buying pasta and I'd done
some press and stuff I'll know the first
meeting you come out I could correct
myself and this woman came up behind me
and it only just released then she
whispered into my ear are you my ELF
maybe have you noticed like our men have
you noticed can you remember like is
there a difference how men are around
you now no like comedy does not lead to
dick Trusteer but it's for women I don't
think it really helps in guys like I
love a funny girl and they're lying like
they love to hang with a funny girl but
they're not like oh I can't wait to hit
that she's a supermodel the dancer Jolla
really just is not exactly that way like
I was like that ever really know my dad
as a princess skinny ankles I had my
mouth was too big there are a lot of
things that were wrong with me and my
eyes didn't like
[Music]
like that you know yeah first wow what a
there's a crazy thing where you're
talking about what's the worst thing
that happened on your date you know we
talked about that and and I forgot but I
threw up to kiss me and it made me sick
I I literally rolled down the window and
I threw up but I said I'm so sorry
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]